über die militärische Situation im Land
sprechen wir jetzt mit ex-nato-general
Egon Rams schönen guten Abend Herr Rams
guten Abend Frau jung
vieles wurde da gerade im Beitrag schon
angesprochen über die aktuelle Situation
insbesondere die Stadt Tressen ist seit
einigen Wochen schwer umkämpft wie
schätzen sie da die aktuelle Lage ein
wie welche Fortschritte macht die
Ukraine tatsächlich wie sieht das da
gerade aus
vielleicht darf ich noch einen Satz
sagen zu dem Besuch des
Bundespräsidenten erschließt alle etwas
unselige Entwicklung ab die ja in den
ist durch diesen Besuch so hoffe ich
abgeräumt ist und damit ein
Schlussstrich gezogen ist und ich meine
das Frank Walter Steinmeier wie immer
als Bundespräsident dieses richtig
gemacht hat nach dem Turbulenzen die wir
im April gehabt haben und nach der
Absage vergangene Woche aus
Sicherheitsgründen jetzt zu KC
haben die Ukrainer weiterhin
Geländegewinne die sich aber ich sage
das mal vorsichtig in einem Rahmen
halten
aufgrund der Tatsache dass der Übergang
die festen Übergänge gestürzt
ich höre sie wieder herab ich hatte
gerade ja ich hätte gerade sie nicht
mehr gehört aber jetzt höre ich sie
wieder ich glaube die Zuschauer haben
sie aber gehört deswegen lassen Sie sich
bitte nicht beirren
ich lasse mich nicht irritieren also die
Brücke über den hier Position zerstört
von daher ist ja auch die
Versorgungslage für die russischen
Truppen auf dem westlichen Ufer des Nepo
schwierig
die Russen versuchen auch hier ich sage
das mal vorsichtig mit bestimmten
Mitteln Stichwort Evakuierung der
Bevölkerung entsprechenden Druck auf die
Bevölkerung auszuüben die Bevölkerung zu
verunsichern das passt eigentlich in das
Bild was Russland russische Soldaten in
der Ukraine überall verbreiten
einschließlich des Beschusses durch
drohen Raketen oder auch
flugzeugangriffe sowohl im westlichen
als auch in anderen Teilen der Ukraine
damit soll die Bevölkerung terrorisiert
werden damit ihr praktisch die Moral
gebrochen wird
die Moral die jetzt für an vielen Orten
noch ungebrochen scheint tatsächlich der
Wiederaufbau ist teilweise in Städten im
gange wo kurz zuvor noch Raketen
runtergegangen sind wir haben viele
Fragen reinbekommen insbesondere zum
Thema Waffenlieferungen die möchte ich
jetzt mal zuerst aufgreifen weil es sich
wirklich gerade bei uns häuft im Chat
und zwar stellt sich hier die Frage ob
auch heute mit dem Besuch des
Bundespräsidenten eben auch das Thema
Panzerlieferungen wieder mehr in den
Fokus rückt Leopard Mader werden da als
Stichwort genannt das kam häufiger die
Frage sehen Sie dafür Zeichen dass ein
Besuch des Bundespräsidenten der ja
nicht der Regierungschef ist aber dazu
führen könnte
nein eigentlich nicht der
Bundespräsident ist der Repräsentant der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland der hat als
solcher die Ukraine besucht dennoch wir
kennen keine Details aus den Gesprächen
zwischen dem Präsidenten selenski und
dem Präsidenten Steinmeier kann es
durchaus sein dass der linski dieses
Thema angeschnitten hat denn die Ukraine
hat weiterhin Bedarf an Waffen an
artilleriewaffen an Artillerie Munition
aber natürlich auch wenn Sie das
Momentum der Angriffe der letzten Wochen
erhalten wollen ein Kampfpanzer und
Schützenpanzer und dieser Bedarf ist
bisher nicht gedeckt von daher muss man
darüber nachdenken ob man dieses Thema
nicht wieder auch von unserer Seite her
neu aufgreifen sollte oder aufgreifen
muss und wir haben ja versucht dieses
über den Ringtausch zu kompensieren und
der Ringtausch ist eine endliche
Geschichte der wird irgendwann aufhören
weil entsprechende Waffensysteme
sowjetischer Bauart oder russischer
Bauer hat dann auch in unseren
Nato-Partner Staaten nicht mehr
vorhanden sind das heißt die Frage kommt
immer wieder hoch und sie kommt immer
wieder auf den Tisch
kommen wir noch einmal auf die ja im
Moment verschiedenen Gebiete in der
Ukraine die im Moment mehr im Fokus
stehen im Beitrag auch angesprochen war
der Staudamm kartoffka es kommt eine
Frage von Daniel Wolf hier bei YouTube
der sich fragt ist der Staudamm und die
Region dort so wichtig weil dort der
nord-krim-kanal beginnt können Sie uns
ein bisschen mehr über die Region und
was was dort eine Rolle spielt
also wenn diese dieser Staudamm zerstört
würde dann würde das auch bedeuten dass
die Wasserversorgung der kriminfrage
gestellt wird denn von daher wäre das
eine Sache die den Russen sehr weh tun
würde dennoch wenn der Staudamm
tatsächlich gesprengt würde würde
erstmal eine Flutwelle sich im Tal des
Nepo ergießen und dadurch wäre die
ukrainische Bevölkerung auch zu großen
Teilen schwer betroffen und von daher
kann ich mir nicht vorstellen dass die
Ukraine diesen Weg gehen wird zumindest
zur Zeit nicht gehen wird weil sie damit
ihre eigenen Bürger gefährden würde und
das kann Präsident selenski und die
ukrainische Führung nicht wollen
außerdem angesprochenen Beitrag der
Vorwürfe Russlands einer schmutzigen
Bombe dafür gibt es keine Beweise wie
gefährlich sind aber solche Vorwürfe aus
Russland was soll damit bezweckt werden
also mit diesen Vorwürfen will man im
Prinzip die Haltung im Westen
unterminieren die die Ukraine der Westen
der die Ukraine entsprechend unterstützt
und wenn man einen solches Bild aufbaut
als Fake News aufbaut dann könnte es
durchaus sein dass beispielsweise die
143 Staaten in der vergangenen Woche
noch die Resolution der Vereinten
Nationen gegen Russland aufgrund des
Angriffskrieges und des Krieges gegen
die Bevölkerung vor allen Dingen
unterstützt haben dann praktisch
abfallen von der von der gemeinsamen
Entscheidung auch dieses sind typische
Erscheinungen eines Hybriden Krieges
Cyber Warfare und Information Warfare
also Informationskrieg die von Russland
im Prinzip seit der gesamten Dauer nicht
nur des Kriege sondern auch bereits
vorher nach der Annektierung der krimen
und der Unruhen beziehungsweise
Separatistenbewegung im Donbass im Jahr
2014 begonnen haben und das ist nicht zu
Ende und das wird weitergehen und die
Zielrichtung geht in zwei dabei das eine
ist einmal die ukrainische Bevölkerung
das andere ist die ich sag mal Welt
draußen und bei der Welt draußen zielt
Russland mit diesen
informationsbedingte Informationskrieg
vor allen Dingen darauf den Westen das
heißt die Europäische Union die NATO zu
spalten und möglicherweise aus der
geschlossenen frontstaaten rauszubrechen
was dann die entsprechende politische
Richtung und Haltung insbesondere der
Europäischen Union sehr deutlich
erschweren würde
ein Informationskrieg das ist es zum
einen das sagen sie richtig ein Krieg
aus der Luft das haben wir in den
letzten zwei Wochen besonders gesehen
und gleichzeitig natürlich schaut man
auch an verschiedene Grenzen auch wieder
mehr an die Grenze im Norden auch der
Bundespräsident ist heute in den Norden
gereist grenzt an Belarus auch dort hat
man in den letzten zwei Wochen
hingeschaut wie der russische
Truppenbewegungen war dort zu sehen wie
schätzen Sie die Gefahr dass jetzt
vielleicht Richtung Winter auch wieder
die Gefahr aus dem Norden eben aus
Belarus kommen könnte wie hoch schätzen
Sie die ein
also ich würde das etwas differenzierter
betrachten es geht nicht um eine Gefahr
aus Belarus der Präsident Lukaschenko
verhält sich dort ausgesprochen
geschickt und nimmt nicht eindeutig
Partei zwar verbal eindeutig Partei aber
nicht mit truppenpartei für Russland
erstellt Flughäfen zur Verfügung alles
Raketen möglicherweise auch Drohnen aus
Belarus abschließen abschließen aber er
selber beteiligt sich nicht am
Kriegsgeschehen mit belausischen
Soldaten und ich glaube er ist ein
kluger Mensch in der Richtung und weiß
dass die Sache nicht entschieden ist
zumindest noch nicht zugunsten von
Russland entschieden ist und hält sich
glaube ich aus diesem Grunde zurück
wobei ich nicht ausschließen kann das
putin war im durchsetzt das russische
Soldaten dann auch vom Boden
Weißrusslands nach Süden angreifen aber
auch da gilt es vor sich zu sein mit der
Lageeinschätzung und das was da
möglicherweise an Aufstellung von
gemeinsamen Verbänden oder dergleichen
im Augenblick in der in den Medien
rumgeistern in der Presse rumgeistert
ist für mich noch kein Beweis dafür das
Belarus in dieser Frage zum
Kriegsteilnehmer wird
was passiert ist in den letzten Wochen
ist das Luftabwehr geliefert wurde auch
aus Deutschland ihres Tees da das System
wurde auch vom ukrainischen Präsidenten
eben in seinem Statement angesprochen
die werden von unserem Reporter in der
Ukraine gehört es wirkt wohl auch die
Luftabwehr sei wirksamer in den letzten
Tagen wie würden sie das Einschätzen
gerade im Hinblick auf die
Drohnenangriffe die es eben auch in Kiew
letzten Montag gab ist das im Moment
ausreichend diese Luftabwehr ist die
Forderung nach mehr der Ukraine
besonders gerechtfertigt aktuell wie ist
da ihre Meinung
also man muss die gesamte Palette sehen
die bisher an Flugabwehrwaffen oder
flugabwehrmitteln an die Ukraine
geliefert worden ist da gehört mit die
fliegerfäuste
red-eye und Stinger die ursprünglich
bereits zu Anfang oder relativ früh
während des Krieges geliefert worden
sind da gehört der Flakpanzer Gebhardt
mit dazu und da gehört jetzt ihres Tee
mit dazu ihr RST ist eines der
modernsten Systeme die wir zurzeit haben
und es wäre gut wenn vor allen Dingen
zur flächendeckenden fluchabwehr mehr
Systeme Ihr System möglichst bald an die
Ukraine geliefert werden können nach
meinem Kenntnisstand ist bisher ein
System da drei weitere Systeme sollen
folgen das waren Systeme die
ursprünglich mal für Ägypten produziert
worden war waren und es gibt noch eine
zweite Variante ihres tslm das wäre ein
System mit einer noch größeren
Reichweite und wenn die deutsche
Industrie und das ist ein deutsches
Produkt in der Lage wäre diese Systeme
sehr schnell zu produzieren und dann
auch entsprechend die zus der
Bundesregierung erfolgt diese an die
Ukraine abzugeben so wäre das für die
Ukraine sehr hilfreich aber ich möchte
noch mal daran erinnern dass auch die
Amerikaner mittlerweile in den letzten
Entscheidungen bekanntgegeben haben dass
Sie die Absicht haben Flugabwehrsysteme
an die Ukraine zu liefern dass die sind
nach meinen Kenntnisstand bisher nicht
eingetroffen aber wenn diese dazu kommen
kann es für die Ukraine eine weitere
Verbesserung geben und es muss das Ziel
der Ukraine sein sowohl gegen Drohnen
als auch Raketen und Flugzeuge eine
funktionsfähige Flugabwehr nach
Möglichkeit über dem ganzen Land
aufzubauen von daher dürfte jede Hilfe
in dieser Richtung in der Ukraine sehr
willkommen sein dann schauen wir noch
einmal auch ein bisschen in die Zukunft
Richtung Ende der Sendung und zwar gab
es ja auch ein internationale Konferenz
in Berlin heute wo es auch eben um
wieder Aufbauhilfen für die Ukraine geht
wir haben eine Frage bei Facebook von
Sven Odenthal der sich fragt wie könnte
ein Marshallplan für die Ukraine
aussehen und eine Integration eines nach
Putin Russlands in ein westliches
Bündnis überhaupt begrüßen
also ich fange mal mit dem zweiten Teil
der Frage an weil das eine Sache ist die
kann man zurzeit nicht beurteilen das
ist selbst ein nachput in Russland ist
für uns ja heute schwer einzuschätzen
und das heißt ja nicht wenn Putin nicht
mehr da ist als Präsident als russischer
Präsident dass sich irgendjemand hinter
ihm herkommt der im Prinzip dieselbe
Politik betreibt das ist eine Sache die
ist für mich im Augenblick
unvorhersehbar und von daher sollte man
in diesem Bereich nicht anfangen zu
spekulieren das muss die Zeit bringen
mit dem anderen Teil mit dem anderen
Teil der Frage es ist schwierig die
Situation in diesem Bereich entsprechend
so zu beurteilen dass man tatsächlich
auch auf bestimmte Ergebnisse rechnen
kann die hier tatsächlich Veränderungen
bringen ich möchte einen Finger möchte
ich warnen heben und zwar in der
Richtung dass ich sage wir sollten nicht
von unserer Seite her auf Verhandlungen
drängen oder über Verhandlungen
entscheiden wollen oder Verhandlungen
anregen sei es mit Putin selber oder sei
es in einer nachblutenzeit einfach aus
dem Grunde so eine Sache ist die die
Ukraine der ukrainische Präsident das
ukrainische Parlament und das
ukrainische Volk entscheiden müssen auf
welcher Basis dann irgendwann
Verhandlungen geführt werden die dann zu
einem Frieden führen können das bringt
mich noch mal zurück auf diese auf diese
Steinmeier auf diese Steinmeier
Vorschlag den wir in den 2000er Jahren
gehabt haben oder nach dem nach Minz 2
gehabt haben wo es ja darum ging das
gesagt worden war das praktisch der Don
Bass mehr oder weniger ausgeklammert
werden sollte ein Sonderstatus bekommen
konnte bekommen sollte und die Krim im
Prinzip nicht Gegenstand irgendwelcher
Gespräche oder der Verhandlung gewesen
wäre
silensky ist glaube ich damals als ihr
junger Präsident hat er dem zugestimmt
weil Putin bei Minz 2 sehr darauf
gedrängt hat es wäre keine Lösung
geworden
ja und eine Frage die da vielleicht auch
noch mal zu stellen ist die ja die
Forderung nach diplomatischen
Verhandlungen wird auch immer wieder
laut zuletzt SPD-Fraktionschef geholfen
Mütze nicht ist dafür die diplomatischen
Anstrengung zu verstärken ist gelte eine
Balance zwischen dem
Selbstverteidigungsrecht der Ukraine und
diplomatischen Initiativen herzustellen
das sagte er bei uns im ZDF sie haben es
eben gerade angesprochen dass man im
Prinzip da die Ukraine wenn ich das
richtig verstanden habe natürlich
lassen muss bzw meine Frage ist
eigentlich wie schätzen Sie das ein
diplomatische Verhandlungen solche
Forderungen solche rufe ist das
gerechtfertigt sollten die überhaupt
kommen in Anbetracht natürlich der Lage
in der sich die Ukraine immer noch
befindet und in dem in dem Stadium in
dem sich dieser Krieg befindet dieser
russische Angriffskrieg
sie hatten vorhin in ihrem Beitrag
angesprochen dass Lars Klingbeil gesagt
hat dass die SPD noch mal prüfen müssen
ob sie in der Vergangenheit mit Blick
auf die Russlandpolitik Fehler gemacht
hat sie sollte das möglicherweise nicht
Überblick auf die Vergangenheit
überprüfen sondern auch auf die aktuelle
Situation wir sollten von unserer Seite
her in dieser Richtung keine Vorschläge
machen die letztendlich die Ukraine in
eine bestimmte Ecke setzen nämlich dass
sie nicht verhandlungswillig ist oder
dergleichen mehr Verhandlungen brauchen
Voraussetzungen die einen entsprechend
erfüllt werden sollen und welche
Voraussetzung das sind darüber
entscheidet die Ukraine und sonst
niemand die Diplomatie ist nicht aus dem
Geschäft es wird miteinander gesprochen
es gibt Verbindung zwischen Russland und
Amerika es gibt Verbindungen zwischen
Russland und der NATO von daher finden
Gespräche weiter statt wie
beispielsweise in den letzten Tagen
zwischen dem russischen
Verteidigungsminister und im
amerikanischen Verteidigungsminister nur
es zeigt sich bei diesen Gesprächen dass
sie im Augenblick nicht sehr produktiv
sind weil offensichtlich Russland sich
immer noch erhofft dass es die vier
annektierten zu Unrecht annektierten
völkerrechtswidrig annektierten Oblaste
vielleicht ganz einnehmen kann und dann
ganz behalten kann und als russisches
Territorium bezeichnen kann man musste
aber einfach feststellen dass von
russischer Seite Rechtsgrundlagen
verändert worden sind in einer Form die
stets zum Nachteil der Ukraine sind und
dass das nicht akzeptabel ist und nicht
akzeptabel wird
sagt ex-nato-general Egon Rams der auch
heute uns wieder mit seiner Analyse
versorgt hat vielen Dank dafür heranz